as of yesterday april 19th every
american is now eligible for the
coronavirus vaccine
within the age ranges approved for each
vaccine that's 18
plus for the moderna vaccine 18 plus for
the johnson
johnson vaccine paused but expected to
be resumed
as soon as friday possibly and 16 plus
for the pfizer vaccine
this was originally going to sort of be
sometime this summer for full
eligibility
then joe biden announced it would be may
1st then joe biden announced in march
that it would be pushed up to april 19th
and we are there and it really couldn't
come at a better time
for two different reasons at least two
different reasons
first of all in some states demand is
slackening for vaccines
states with more republicans 43 percent
of whom do not plan to get this vaccine
have more vaccine hesitancy and so
they are starting to see in some sense
more supply than demand
and so opening vaccination eligibility
to more people
will hopefully boost vaccination numbers
and keep going with vaccinating you know
three to four million people per day
secondly because of the johnson and
johnson vaccine being paused
vaccine numbers have been slightly
declining and we want to
keep things going the u.s is still
averaging a very strong
3.19 just short of 3.2 million vaccine
doses per day
and we want to grow that number and
thirdly expanding eligibility to all
adults and then 16 plus for the pfizer
vaccine is important because we are
really in a race against variants
which some countries are winning and we
want to get there too
there is a lot of doom and gloom about
the variance the variance nothing
nothing works it's just a disaster
if you look at cases and deaths in the
uk
the source of the british b117 variant
cases are now down to 96 per day that's
not
96 per capita it's just 96 cases per day
um that is down i'm sorry the cases are
down
96 from their peak in mid-january
if you look at israel another highly
vaccinated country
cases are now down more than 98
and uh these are countries with many
variants when you look at a country like
israel and in israel it's been all
vaccination they are around 56 percent
fully vaccinated
around 50 percent cases started to fall
off a cliff and go close to zero
in the uk the vaccination has been more
modest
but the guidelines have been significant
and the uk is actually only 15 fully
vaccinated but at 50 percent partial and
that is absolutely huge as well
in the us right now we are at 25
fully vaccinated and 40 partially as of
a few days ago
numbers probably a little bit better by
now based on that
we are probably if we can keep this
going 30 or so days
remember two weeks ago we said it was
probably 35 to 45 days we are probably
about 30 days
from significant improvements here but
people need to get vaccinated and now
with full eligibility hopefully that
will happen
my 17 year old sister got her first dose
this week just about everybody i know
has had one dose already
things are moving in the right direction
now sadly
one pulse says it's 20 another says it's
30
at least 20 percent of the country
simply doesn't want the vaccine
and most of them are republicans 43
percent of republicans as we talked
about last week and i mentioned earlier
do not want the vaccine and that's a
major problem now over time
with more and more colleges saying if
you want to come back to campus you need
a vaccine
more and more venues and businesses and
even foreign countries saying
if tourists want to come here they will
need to be vaccinated
hopefully these numbers will improve
just get your vaccine
don't lose sleep over the mega clowns
for now 80
is still enough for herd immunity let's
do what we can
now and then deal with the people
who selfishly will not get vaccinated
due to ignorance due to disdain due to
political misunderstandings due to
conspiracism
whatever the case may be let's keep
going we have
potentially authorization coming from
multiple vaccines
for the 12 to 15 and 12 to 17 age ranges
for the respective vaccines tests being
done
uh to look at expanding it even further
so all of this is going in the right
direction for now i mean listen i've
said before i i get it it's frustrating
to see people
who could get vaccinated and who say i'm
not going to and they could spread it
and then they could give it to somebody
who's not able to get the vaccine or who
is in the five percent that by by
you know odds don't develop immunity and
then some of those people will die like
i get it
but let's focus on what we can control
and now that we have full vaccine
eligibility
you can get vaccinated that's the most
important thing and we're going to
continue following what happens with jnj
and what happens with vaccine hesitancy
and the whole thing
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and delicious
like the cereals
you loved as a kid without the sugar
without the carbs
magic spoon tastes just like those
sugary cereal brands
we all loved but it has zero grams of
sugar four net carbs
13 to 14 grams of protein so it's
perfect for anyone following
a keto or low carb diet or just
people like me who want to avoid sugar
magic spoon has just
relaunched the blueberry flavor one of
my favorites it comes in cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon
you can also get a variety pack and try
them all magic spoon is so confident in
how delicious
their cereal is you get all your money
back if you don't absolutely
love it they'll give you five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link
underneath this video